jimmy kimmel uh this is what happened i
can't believe i i still i was
dude this was one of those that i saw
while i was taking my my
weekend my nice first dump of the day
just sitting there hanging out you know
you're having a smoke and i'm like
oh my god is he is this real
yeah so he he tweeted uh this is this
this was i was like this can't be real
so uh jon stewart by the way let's let's
let's let's call let's call a spade a
spade
excuse me i apologize it's n word dude
see i wish this was ten years ago where
i could have just said oh dude
it's my grandfather always say let's
call an n word in edward
old family saying but let's call the
spade a spade here okay
jon stewart is historically known as
bidding just like this hard right
releaning guy you know jon stewart is
his right-wing dude as right-wing as it
gets yeah blitzkrieg john stewart yeah
yeah you know what i call you know what
i call the daily show the fourth reich
that's what i called it um jon stewart
says uh this is [ __ ] jon stewart's
one of those
that would have ratted out other jokes
back in the day
that's the kind of yeah let's see the
fascist yes three of them right next
door i know it's
crazy i think of fascist jon stewart
yeah so john stewart
famous here jon stewart
[Laughter]
[Music]
well remember he did all that [ __ ] for
911 for the who
the cops and the firefighters you know
statist
bootlicker so oh these firefighters have
cancer
[ __ ] bootlicker [ __ ] so sick of
john stewart that's all you care about
all you hear about today is all you hear
about every day is jon stewart because
it's 2006.
strange too because we care about all
these firefighters from 9 11. i
specifically remember breathing that air
too
for the same amount of time
[ __ ] you how about we kick me a couple
of bucks yeah well there's my trillion
dollars looks like you have the whole
dust and diamond coming your way
so i want to get stabbed at a bar in
wisconsin oh no
by a hooker sex tape over probably
was probably a half a gram of coke so
when you think of look mike
when you think of jon stewart what do
you think of the second best host of the
daily show after craig kilbourne
and um he tweeted crimes
i also think he hates thinking the many
many
violent white nationalist hate crimes he
was involved once it was announced that
trevor noah was replacing him
john sir was quoted as saying they're
hiring a what
that's true john stewart said that it's
crazy not people don't really look into
this guy
it is actually close to what he probably
really said which is they're hiring who
is that what so
um look jon stewart
tweeted this out um jon stewart says
this is [ __ ] the redditors aren't
cheating they're joining
a party wall street insiders have been
enjoying for years
don't shut them down maybe sue them for
copyright infringement instead
not a great joke doesn't have his riders
anymore you could tell
but a joke nonetheless and i think
probably a sentiment that we all agree
with
because that's the thing with this wall
street stuff everybody is pretty much
for the most part
politics aside it's kind of been on the
same side of course [ __ ] these guys
you know um jimmy kimmel
uh most famously known for being a
sports broadcaster and on the man show
retweeted him and wrote real donald
trump is this you
now a question well can i
first of all let's first of all number
one
no it's not okay just i just thought i'd
let jimmy know that
i don't know what else we're adding to
our points but the first point would be
no jimmy that's jon stewart host of the
daily show former host
now during his uh monologue for his show
he had some things to say so why don't
we play a little bit of that huh
gamestop if you don't know it's a video
game store and like a lot of businesses
they've been struggling because of
covert but also
you know what else has been strong i
have to back up just a little bit sorry
it's a short clip but we're breaking
down you know what's been struggling a
lot since uh since covert late night tv
shows
and like a lot of businesses they've
been struggling because of covert but
also
because most people buy games online now
and yet despite a sharp decline in sales
over the past six months their stock
price has grown by eight
thousand percent because a bunch of
amateur investors
maybe even some russian disruptors who
remember the reason
the people that are really behind this
okay
when you really follow this is of course
russia russian disruptors it's clearly
been
uh russians from day one i mean they
want to undermine
uh this this great biden presidency is
what it is
it's russian disruptors they're the ones
that are doing this now biden just met
with the russians right
yes so they control him clearly yes okay
you know who controls him anyone who has
his hard candies in their pockets anyone
who's standing in front of him yeah
and talking to him at that moment yes
he's that he's that kind of a
career politician listen i want to
legalize
drunk driving you got it pal i'm gonna
talk to
me and kamal are gonna sit in the back
we're gonna have a chat about it buddy
you know like there's no way he's gonna
leak less drunk driving
eight thousand percent because a bunch
of amateur investors
rush into [ __ ]
amateur hours over okay why don't you go
back to the peanut gallery
you [ __ ] scumbag you disgusting by
the way don't make [ __ ] eye contact
with me
you want to come be an audience member
at this show don't even [ __ ] look at
me yeah the guy who used to put a wig
and blackface on it pretend to be
oprah's telling you you're a piece of
[ __ ] and the way they like
moral and the way they like pontificate
you know i always compare these guys to
the old days but like
if this had been the old days of
letterman and leno they would have made
a crack about it
and moved on that would have been it it
would have been
letterman would have came out and it
would it would have been in passing he
would have said
it would have been some other joke about
something and something about cbs not
paying him and it would have been like
and it got so bad i had to sell some of
my game stock
like just like as a wink but these guys
have to do a 10 minute like guys
this isn't funny you're robbing my
billionaire friends like
they would have never done that in the
90s in the 90s he would have made a
quick reference to amc
stock and it would have been moving on
and everybody would have giggled because
they'd be like oh i get that that's
yeah thing that's it this [ __ ] is so
i hate these people now man like at
least could you at least squeeze a
little bit of entertainment into our
propaganda
just a little bit so uh amateur
investors
maybe even some russian disruptors who
are part of a reddit community called
wall street bets
decided to buy a bunch of gamestop stock
so no but by the way not even the media
has said
that these russians deserve nobody has
said this
he's so stupid he's a stupid man
like you could tell he's he's good at
hosting his little show and
telling you whatever they tell you him
to tell you but
there's there is not a lot going on
upstairs with jimmy kimmel like that his
brain went to russian
interference because you can tell he's
trying to be creative like i'll go out
there
and i'll i'll i'll do my own twist on it
you know because we all got to go out
there do a full court press and stop
these people
and he's the only one to be like maybe
it's i don't know russian interference
who knows like he's just so stupid
but the thing that blows my mind is that
remember occupy wall street and all that
that was all that that was you know
for the most part a left-wing thing that
happened initially and
and people like kimmel at the if this
was going on when he had his
the show would have been all for it
would have been like yeah you know
[ __ ] the corporations man how the left
has gone
not all of them but how because there's
a lot of people that still hate him but
how how the mainstream how about this
them how the mainstream left
has gone from [ __ ] these big
corporations man to
literally sucking their [ __ ] [ __ ] on
national television well they've been
that way for
for a while now i mean it's this whole
you know global citizens concert and
everything's just been like
yeah my my my point of view is supported
by
citibank yeah so uh
he did he did throw in a little bit of
comedy you want to see the comedic uh
angle he took i'll [ __ ] i'm gonna
scream sure
it's good it's a good community you know
the problem with mike is is that he
doesn't really understand good comedy so
let's just check it out
something like that i said it was
confusing
for most people it is so we got in touch
with an expert
to explain this to us and we were able
to find
okay i'm sorry are you noticing
something with jimmy
is he tired on drugs or just had a
facelift
look at his eyes are really glassy yeah
they're red too though i think he smokes
a lot of weed again i
does he i think well yeah he just looks
blunted like he doesn't look like he
doesn't necessarily look like he's on
drug drugs
but he does look like a little drunk or
maybe a little high or maybe a little
combination about like he doesn't strike
me as a guy that's eating [ __ ]
pain pills and benzos and doing coke but
he strikes me as one of those
old-fashioned miserable hollywood guys
that probably drinks and smokes a lot of
pot
he just looks out but again this goes
back to my point of saying that like
he's not a smart guy like he he's very
like
maybe it's a russian interference like
his he's burnt out like that's
you can tell that's a guy who truly
doesn't have to think a lot
and hasn't really exercised his brain
muscle much so he's like i don't know
but yeah he looks that looks like just
kind of drinking pot
the the sloppy low end habits
he got in touch with an expert to
explain this to
us and we were able to find someone who
knows a lot about money and
video games who do you think you got
like so if you got some big money in
video games what do you think you got
um the who's this gotta be both uh
who's the minecraft guy oh notch notch
yeah he got now i would be my guest or
mary moto the nintendo guy the guy who
found it who
who really blew an intent that'd be a
pity pretty baguette in my guy who likes
to sue people
yeah um they love that
he really doesn't
do you see them on tim pool talking
about that the guy was like oh yeah they
kicked my shirt off that tim but his
costumes like they kicked my t-shirt off
teespring because i had somebody peeing
on a cnn logo or whatever
or like or it was like a bunch of logos
like media logos and he's like they took
my thing down and they were like
arguing over whether or not he's allowed
to do it because it's fair use and it's
like
furious doesn't apply to logos like it
was funny watching him try to
rationalize and he's like
what i could do like what if i wanted to
do like an intent he literally said
nintendo he's like
what if i did a shirt that had nintendo
but it had somebody like
you know peeing on the nintendo or
whatever and i was like just talking to
the air and i was like please do that
please make a t-shirt with the nintendo
logo on it i'd like you to meet the
litigious nintendo corporation
because if you even somebody even in the
chat that night said
if you think about mario for too long
nintendo will suit you
so let's check this out to us and we
were able to find someone
who knows a lot about money and video
games and he's joining us now
uh from uh
[Applause]
oh look at this it's mario
do they they don't care anymore right
like this is mario no but this is like
guys getting together
to do their writing meeting and they're
like i don't know we get mario
get a mario costume come on i don't know
we don't need red lines just wing it
but it's it's not even look the bit's
bad to begin with
but you couldn't even do something a
little bit more topical than mario like
i don't know man like even though it's
even this is still old but like you know
we oh so we got the
minecraft guy yeah but i do think that
it's also
like as far as like any v how about this
interviewing any video game character
would be just a stupid
awful premise but i i get why it's mario
because mario's the most
recognizable like i guess somebody hates
you
well sonic's fine but he's not mario
it's just
like the look you [ __ ] sega [ __ ] can
cry all you want but nobody's ever going
to
hey you had the sega channel yeah i love
sega but
let's stop pretending like mario from
mario brothers isn't the most
famous it's a cope it's a cope i'll
admit i'm coping a little
i mean sonic rules but you and most i
would say this if you showed sonic in
front of the whole planet
i'd say 70 to 80 percent of the planet
would go oh [ __ ] sonic
all japan would get it but if you showed
mario 99 like
there would be [ __ ] uh african
children
trying to say mario with a series of
clicks and whistles because they would
even recognize
mario mario's is one of those things you
look and go oh [ __ ] by the way 12 packs
said
oh hey look uh oh never mind i thought
he was making a joke
bonus sarah to you mario by the way
mario what is your last name
ah is a lopez
see royce mario lopez is a world famous
actor
from saved by the bell first off lopez
is a stupid last name
that's from recipe for seduction sorry i
i didn't pick his
top credit no that might be his top
credits
recipe and lopez is a stupid last name
um
mario's a stupid name too though it's a
combination of stupid soaps
here you go mike i like to play let's
play a quick game here how would you
if you were writing that i know you
would never do this premise i understand
this premise is stupid
but what would you do next to try to
make this funny this feels like one of
those snl sketches where they just
needed an excuse to use bobby moynihan
i don't know we're not using bobby
enough can we do a mario thing
uh what do i think he did the joke is
yeah
um i mean besides the entire show
what is the joke uh i don't know but i
hope mario makes a crack about his kid's
heart condition
okay that would be funny it would be
very edgy can you imagine
slow like mario lopez yes that's
why i don't use a lasting name okay
mario's last name is mario it's mario
mario and luigi mario so
[ __ ] do your research all right
now mario can you please explain this uh
game stop
can you explain it please explain this
bit to me like what's the point of it
you know what i mean look a lot of
people might not like jon stewart
but you [ __ ] dare put jon stewart
down when you're airing this garbage jon
stewart's the [ __ ]
goat compared to you jimmy this is this
is [ __ ] hot trash
say whatever you want about and but i
can't say like i don't like john
stewart's politics and he annoys me and
stuff but like
having gone to that show so many times
when i was a kid and like meeting jon
stewart and stuff like he was always
such a nice guy
he seems like a relatively nice person
and his show
was better for a longer period of time
than your show
of course now mario can you please
explain this
uh gamestop reddit stock market
yours our course is it like this okay
is it like this they pretend there's a
late night show that's not getting a
good
ratings so what they do is they
artificially increase the numbers so
jimmy kimmel gets to stay on the air
okay uh you uh you have a coin yes
yeah and you you you say hey i like this
coin i want a more coin so yeah what do
you do
alora you jump up and you get the coin
now you got to do coins and then you say
hey i like these coins
maybe get a whole lot of coins i keep it
jumping i keep on jumping i get
more coins maybe you get a heat in the
corner
you know what it is like sometimes we'll
watch a thing and you'll go like this
isn't very funny
or whatever right like this isn't very
funny but
this is making me angry am i the only
one that's getting like
angry from this is is anyone else
angry at this
yeah look at all of these are going
through yeah yeah
it's not really clearing it up for me
hey but can i is it still okay to do an
italian stereotype is this
it's kind of insane
is he something's up man something's up
for sure
he's i mean he's seen he looks high he
looks like
weed high like yeah just like again man
i i think that despite
like it feeling like they're winning
these people are just falling apart and
i think a lot of them
it's a lot of them are having to come to
terms with
the fact that they they put
so much energy into we got to get rid of
trump we got to get rid of trump
trump is trump is the reason why
i'm sad trump is the reason why children
are dying
trump is the reason why there's a black
cloud over the planet
we need to get trump out of here and
they worked so hard to cheat and get
trump out and now they're like
i don't feel any different i feel no
different i think that's starting to
sink in with some of these people where
this was supposed to be the biggest
victory for them ever and they're like
i don't feel any better and in fact in
some cases they feel worse
and they're like i don't this was
supposed to be magic now
and it's not and they're realizing like
oh god and i think a lot of them are
just
like especially with covid no movie
theaters no films there's nothing going
on
these people are drinking and eating
pills and just getting
[ __ ] up because what else would you do
like it's got to be miserable
that's got to be a miserable existence
like we can just do our show anywhere
like it's
like podcasters and and streamers are
killing it you know shows like us or
shows like adonis paul and [ __ ] they're
like
i'm still around what's up homies we're
doing a show thursday night see you
later
but like these guys have to have celebs
and a film to promote and a big band and
a live audio they need all this [ __ ] and
they're like there's not we're not
allowed to leave the house you got to
wear 17 masks
and everybody's like it's they've really
created a situation where they all just
want to die
they all want to die right now and uh
well let's finish my spirit hey but can
i is it still okay to do an italian
stereotype is this
it's kind of insulting no
can i have a jewish stereotype a guy can
i do that i just did one with the coins
what are you talking about fair enough
insulting
you talking to my brother and luigi he's
a filthy he's dead
you know how italia is a shepard
yeah luigi's dad luigi he's a dog a poop
and the boot is stepped on
well that seems very offensive mario
ah my dinner she's a phoenix oh
okay oh right
that looks very good what are you having
is
uh-huh mushroom pasta i love the
mushrooms huh
uh-huh oh yeah you gotta be careful
oh he turned bigger because he ate he
ate a
mushroom
so it's not even this do you understand
if if
like somebody did this on their youtube
show
this would be unacceptable yeah that's
on
that's abc i want to point out that
that's
abc disney big networks that's that's
like
the eight that's abc it's it's this is
eight do you understand that he's
supposed to be abc's carson
i just wanna i wanna really paint the
picture of you he's supposed to be the
jay leno of abc and that sketch
looks like it belongs on the [ __ ]
quarterings channel
right like no i take you know what
that's an insult to the court because
the quartering would be like
can we get the lighting to be better
could we at least get a better mario
costume
this is no i bad
the mushrooms they make me grow a big no
no
then a fake laugh somebody has to laugh
but it's like
you hear that like it's not even a good
fake laugh because
even he's just like this bit's terrible
it's everybody here is miserable
it's the only comfort i take anymore is
that for everybody on our side of the
culture war or whatever we think we're
miserable or whatever
they're so unhappy and it's that's the
like joy i take is the fact that i know
the enemy isn't happy as we are
because this is not a sketch written in
a writing room full of happy writers
having a good
this is a sketch written in a writing
room full of guys that know
they can't write anything problematic
they can't write anything that makes fun
of
people they can't make fun of black
people they can't make fun of anything
anymore
and they're like i don't know we get
mario and he eats some [ __ ] mushroom
thing and he gets big
it's it's it's not topical
it's stupid um and like you pointed out
that's the thing i was going to say it's
like you know most youtubers could pull
this off better
like you know and we [ __ ] on crowder and
we probably will but
crowder skits look better than this yeah
they are
filmed better than this they are they
are i hate stephen crowder but
objectively speaking just as far as the
quality goes like i'm not saying it
would be funny
but just as far as the costume quality
and like
the lighting and the way like the back
and forth between the two people
steven crowder would have been like we
gotta let's film it again let's just
keep going like we got to get this at
least kind like
crowder at least understands if you're
if you're shoveling [ __ ] at people
you got to at least do it with a big
smile and a big hey
about it a big musical number like crowd
or say what you want at least he brings
energy
to it [ __ ] this is these this is a whole
group of people that don't want to be
there
they just nobody wants to be there that
laugh gave it away when he was just like
ah
nice you know you brought something up
that i that i think was a really good
idea and i haven't really thought about
it but you
you know in 2016 when trump won
there was for a couple months maybe
three months there was a nice bubble
there where the people that won
you know the maga movement that won were
actually happy they were legitimately
happy
it wasn't fake it wasn't put on there
was a little time there for three months
everyone was like yeah [ __ ] yeah our guy
won
they haven't had that have you the left
hasn't been happy they're miserable
they've never been happy no but but your
guy won this is the guy you wanted he
won why are you still so [ __ ] sad all
the time
he signed like 53 executive orders
yeah because they hate themselves
ah that's right and that's the problem
see that's your problem is that
if you if you had realized four years
ago that you're true
or not even four years ago even longer
ago when all this woke [ __ ] started if
all of you would just realize in life
that all of the things that are making
you unhappy
you have much more control over them
than
everyone else around you like i know on
their side it's white men and
colonizers and patriarchy that's ruining
everything
and then everybody on our side's guilty
of it too everything's the jews
but like you could actually just
like if you're not happy figure out what
you did the last couple of days
get up tomorrow and do whatever the
exact opposite of that is
and see if you're happier like these
people don't realize that
they're unhappy because they're unhappy
so they just go well it's trump
if trump got out of office i would be a
ball of sunshine
like these people have convinced
themselves that would be like me saying
like you know what man if i just quit
drinking i'll be a ball of sunshine like
no i won't like
it's for people to believe that to think
if i get rid of this one problem
i'm gonna be better and it's like no you
in order to be better you have to make a
conscious effort
to be happier these people are [ __ ]
miserable
and they're always going to blame an
external source the entire left is
is is predicated on blaming
all of your problems on an outside
source that's
completely their conditioning like it's
the same way like the right wing
tends to to be like all right like like
in
they'd be a little more individualist so
they'll go like woman
i'm not making enough money what can i
do
to make more money like that's how they
think but the left thinks like
i don't have enough money clearly jeff
bezos is it faultier
you know and it's like well wait a
minute no that's not how it works
so yeah they're just they're going to
continue to be unhappy
um and i it's it sucks because they're
going to keep
shaping policies and shaping things to
try to make themselves happy
and they'll burn the whole planet down
before they're ever happy
now you're right and you know it's i
i say that just by look i'm sure
everyone in this chat could even relate
to this
when trump won it was
hilarious right like seeing the left
people the left crying and like
bawling and like and you know
and the trump people were laughing you
know the maggot people were just
laughing and were you [ __ ] idiots
you [ __ ] thought you were going to
win blah blah blah blah when it comes
now to biden winning i don't see
any of that on the other side like i
don't see joy
i only see they're still attacking trump
trump hasn't said anything in like a
month
and they're still attacking him yeah and
he hasn't done anything i mean guys
haven't done anything jimmy kimmel's
seeing them everywhere i know
it's like dude there's no joy like
you should be happy spike the football
be happy about that you're winning but
the truth is you you're not happy
because
did this isn't this isn't what you
wanted and like you said
what they want is not attainable you
know
that what they want is to okay and i
said this is a victim culture thing
right what they want is to be perpetual
victims
victimhood's been monetized if you're a
victim you're gonna get on the news
you're gonna get a gofundme you're gonna
make four hundred thousand dollars for
for riding out your dad to the fbi like
we've monetized victimhood
so the moment you're not the victim
anymore the moment you're winning the
moment you're the guy
you're like well but know what
but now now do something go go do
something with it you guys are the
winners
go figure it out and if you think that
stopping the [ __ ] pipeline or
letting people into the military is
gonna make you happy
you're chasing a dragon it's like heroin
you know you're you're
you're chasing this dragon and you're
never going to feel it you're never
you're never going to be happy and
that's why jimmy kimmel's [ __ ]
like all of these shows that that made
that built their entire
career around making fun of trump the
stephen colbert's the [ __ ] jimmy
kimmels
the their entire life is trump trump
trump
their ratings were already going down
they're going to plummet even more
because nobody wants to hear jimmy
kimmel's [ __ ] take on
you you can't go jimmy kimmel's take on
a former president
yeah that's unheard of like it's maybe
once in a while you get a former
president joke in a monologue but
they're still obsessed with a former
president it's the first time in history
that's ever happened
like there wasn't [ __ ] 10 more years
of reagan after reagan left
[ __ ] reagan like but you can't you
also can't go from building your entire
show on criticizing one person
or a group of people and saying they're
all [ __ ] evil in the russian assets
and they're dictators and this and that
you can't go from that and then after
they're gone going hey here's a wacky
news headline
like people be like you know what how do
you do that how do you go
from doing that that's like having to
show cops like right everyone wants us
cops to see the police chases and take
them down
and one day cops just decides we're
still going to cover cops
with them doing paperwork and people be
like i don't want to watch cops doing
paperwork
nobody wants the watch that would be
great house cats is filmed in
a [ __ ] police office
hey uh i'm gonna go get some coffee will
you guys want to
did you guys want to write down what
kind of coffee you guys want
bad boys that's all it would be i'm
gonna head down to wawa you guys want
anything maybe
oh no i'm cool man thanks i'm taking a
lunch order but no drinks
yeah not taking any drinks in my car
remember that old gig
you can't do any of this so i just think
it's funny to me
i'd still think it's funny that they
they're not getting the
they're not getting the resounding win
that they thought that they were gonna
get they're not getting that
they're not getting the adrenaline rush
it's not the word they're not getting
the adrenaline
they thought they'd been watching cape
[ __ ] movies for the past
20 years and they thought that like you
know
trump would like have to give up the
infinity stones and then
through magic no i'm serious it just
makes me laugh but this is what these
people are emotionally conditioned to
like
to like people in capes standing around
in the avengers theme playing
and then everybody's happy but it's like
that's not life like life is gonna be
mostly just you being unhappy i hate to
break that news to you
but that's mostly life it's like that
line in the wire that's what life is
it's the [ __ ] that happens while you sit
around waiting for stuff that never
comes like
that's that's life that's exactly what
life is
uh ross river has a really good point he
goes i take pleasure in colbert having
to be the gerbils of the left
instead of the heir to letterman cause
that's what you are you're not the heir
to
letterman now you're just the dude who
is just the propaganda piece for an
entire [ __ ]
political party yeah i mean i have a
feeling if these guys were around
still like i i feel like if letterman
and leno were around
i don't think you'd see as much of this
because i don't think i think they'd be
poked fun of course but i don't think no
they would they would they would
obviously
make their positions known more but the
whole like if the network was like look
we need more trump stuff like that that
was the last generation of late-night
hosts that were able to be like
oh yeah no i hear your dog but i don't
give a [ __ ] what you want
so it's in my contract i've been here
since the 90s i mean you could pretty
much suck my dick
because nobody's gonna like they had a
little more nobody's gonna tell me what
the [ __ ] to do
these other guys le the the ratings are
slipping
they when your ratings are slipping and
you're the new guy
or the new ish guy you kind of have to
do what the network says like you're not
you're not in a position where it's like
leno when leno was at the top spot
they could have been like uh jay we want
you to start talking about trump more
and he could just go well you know i'm
not really interested in that
i don't really care like and they would
have to go look we can't really press
the leno as you
he makes us a lot of money and if he
doesn't want to do the trump stuff
can't tell him to do the trump stuff
what we'll do is we'll get a guy after
him or before him
and they'll do like a full hour of trump
stuff like that's what they would do
but nowadays you got steep like you
think stephen colbert has pull at cvs
like no of course not not like the old
guys well they learned their lesson
but you're right once those contracts
were over once they expired
they weren't going to make this a couple
reasons uh
late night tv wasn't what it was before
so they didn't have they didn't need
anybody to be a [ __ ] rock star like a
letterman or a leno or a carson you
didn't need rock stars anymore
you just needed somebody to to fill a
seat you needed somebody to fill the
scene and be reasonably funny
because look before all the internet's
thing blew up like
love them or hate them either leno or
letterman the next day when you were
were people like hey did you guys watch
did you see leno last night that was
pretty funny he had blah blah blah and
i'll be like hey did you see letterman
last night he had
dude he had this gun it was great nobody
i've never heard anybody go hey
did you watch fallon last night i'd be
like who are you
are you a time traveler bonnie donegan
lonnie donegan no nobody did um dude i
was watching
it's funny this topic came up because it
showed up in my recommended is i watched
a montage of just letterman like
somebody cut up all the letterman stuff
from when
jay and conan were fighting that's so
good
dude the amount of just brutal
[ __ ] on carson daly that was amazing
he just wouldn't dude he's [ __ ] on
carson daly more than
anybody else he didn't do anything
nothing to him
no and then it's like he would just go
so the story is like you know jay
went to 10 o'clock and then conan took
over the tonight show and then
j show wasn't doing great and conan's
wasn't doing good with the lead in so
then they wanted to move conan back
and they were going to give jay back at
11 30. still have conan host
the tonight show but at 1205 and then he
goes
which i mean at that point that's not
even the tonight show that's
that's the tomorrow show that's that's
the tom snyder show
tomorrow show so he's like pointing all
that out he goes and then you know we
you know they're they're saying we don't
know what we're gonna do with jay we
don't know what we're gonna do with
conan we don't even know who carson daly
is like he would just i know i thought
[ __ ] on like
everything every time he would mention
that stuff and he'd go
and i don't know this carson daly is
that even how he goes look
having a show at 2 30 and not having a
show i mean the difference is like
watch the compilations of that non-stop
carson daly shots and i'm like what did
he do to you
um well then he said uh then they said
something about you know what well i
think we're going to get them all in
here i'm going to get jay in here i want
to get conan in here we're going to sit
down
if carson daly wants to show up i'm sure
we can get a folding chair or something
it was just like why
what did he do i hate carson daly what
did he do to you
i would take a hundred cars and dailies
over one lily sing to be honest with you
oh no he honestly you know you're right
because carson daly at least can host a
show yeah he can
like lily's one of those that's like i'm
gonna be funny i'm gonna put my
stamp on late night carson daly's a guy
that's like
what are my notes what are the jokes
that your white male writers wrote for
me thank you i will memorize these
that's all you need